Joseph Tsushima is a vast beautiful game
you'll be eager to explore but even with
its traditional open world trappings you
may need a little more than the wind to
guide you whether it's tips for
sharpening your combat or some basics to
get more out of the game here are 9
things you should know before starting
ghost of Tsushima character tales are
side quests that pop up as you recruit
more of the characters who support Jin
in defending the island of Tsushima once
you have them on your side
these quest lines will open up and these
are the important ones you'll want to
take on doing so not only provides more
insight into who these characters are
but gets you new gear and upgrades as
you progress in them it's also worth
noting that character tales are written
to be played alongside the main story
and if you hold off on them till the
late-game these stories won't really hit
the same combat can be challenging even
more so if you don't take advantage of
its systems the game will remind you at
times if you're not engaging with the
various stances you unlock and you
should heed that advice if not for the
first time stances work as a sort of
rock-paper-scissors matchup where
certain stance is more effective against
an enemy using a certain type of weapon
allowing you to stagger enemies quickly
for easier kills as a side note one
upgrade along the wind stance path lets
you Auto parry spirit acts when you
attack so get that one you can when you
get into pretty big combat scenarios
you're often overwhelmed by the number
of enemies coming after you there will
be a mix of swordsmen spearmen and
sometimes brutes since archers hang back
and fire away they'll often interrupt
any sort of combat rhythm you can
predict when they fire by their voice
lines but it's better just to get them
out of the way first
there are also easy targets since they
don't have the gear to defend themselves
up close you might be inclined to
reserve air O's for long-range
situations but your boat can be clutched
for thinning out enemies at close range
it's pretty satisfying to activate
concentration and line up a headshot to
take down an enemy that's charging at
you and since there's such a short delay
between pulling out your bow
putting away your bow and putting up
your guard you don't have to leave
yourself vulnerable when clearing out
Mongol camps you're often asked to do
optional objectives in addition to
killing the camp leader these aren't
just for
completionists sneaking around to find
the leader and observe the leader before
making the assassination is important
doing so grants an extra point to your
stance unlock progression meter so you
can get them quicker other objectives
give you more legend XP smoke bombs are
intended to obscure the enemy's vision
so you can flee a large mob and make
your escape if you're in danger but
actually this is a prime opportunity to
get some easy kills smoke bombs
essentially put you into a stealth state
and if you have the chain assassination
skill maxed you can get three easy kills
before dipping out or gathering yourself
to take on the rest each set of a tire
carries its own unique attributes that
much is clear when you acquire them and
see them in menu but it's easy to forget
swapping them for the right situation so
this is your reminder when roaming about
where the travelers attire to uncover
more of the map area as you explore
which can mark key locations from
further out and make your controller
pulse when collectibles are nearby if
you're going into sneaky missions swap
in the ronin attire and if you're going
head-on into battle always have your
samurai armor ready it's a quick swap in
the menu that will give you an edge
whatever the situation more armor sets
unlock throughout the game but these are
the key ones towards the beginning major
charms offer beefier buffs than minor
charms that much is clear but you can
only get two slots for major charms so
don't waste them on minor charms one of
the key location types to seek out is
the Inari shrines finding these unlock
extra minor charm slots if you see a fox
out in the open follow them to wherever
they lead now one particularly good
major charm to find at the start is me
zone alchemy which makes timing windows
for perry's a bit wider parrying is
probably the most important combat
mechanic to master so this charm will
make your life much easier
you can spend technique points to unlock
the guiding wind Peart that will lead
you to important spots that offer
upgrades like the hot springs to boost
health or shrines to find more charms
these aren't just things to check off of
a list since they have a fairly
significant impact on your ability to
survive and thrive in combat you can
check all the locations of the hot
springs bamboo stress
shinto shrines and more on gamespot calm
and circumvent it all together if you
prefer those are just some of the basics
you should keep in mind and make habits
in the early goings of ghosts of
Tsushima we also have an advanced combat
guy that goes into detail for becoming a
top-notch samurai or ghost so check that
out here on GameSpot thanks for watching
[Music]
you